and i'm genuinely concerned and this is
in no way like some kind of an attack or
or i'm trying to get you or anything
but i'm legitimately curious looking at
all of your
postings all of your texts all of you
know you just spent a million dollars on
a single youtube video you're giving out
bitcoins which are 30 grand to like
people if they comment
on an instagram post like you're buying
cars for people like it's no big deal
you're throwing away jewelry off
balconies like
diamonds necklaces you're tossing them
off balconies i mean
you are being so reckless with money i
have to try to figure out i can't help
but be so curious
if you're like highly strategic and very
calculated in all of these moves where
you're
you're spending money to make money or
if you're just
[ __ ] out of control or if you just
like have that much money that you
genuinely don't care but
in this day and age it's a pretty wild
nerve like you know because
like like the way i look at the world
and i know i'm talking a lot i gotta let
you get in here
it's so funny yeah like let me just just
shut the [ __ ] up
keep going keep going it's just
hilarious okay the way i look at the
world
the the one percent has all the money
and everyone else is [ __ ] hurt
you know so to have a lifestyle where
you're like
like kind of flossing where you're like
like you know showing how much
wealth you have and spending money and
throwing money around
like i think a lot of you know
man i don't have that much money but
like i'm sensitive to it you know like i
wouldn't want to be
like never wanted to be flashy you know
and like i know that
when you're throwing around money you're
typically giving it away to people
you're being like uh
you know what you call it like a
philanthropist
you know you're being a kind and
generous person which is cool
but what are your thoughts about being
only [ __ ] 22 years old
and and throwing like does any part of
you think i gotta be careful and save
just because [ __ ] i might live until i'm
80. no
and no so there's zero part of me that
feels like that way
because um i'm so like confident in
myself
because like if i'm tripping like five
years from now
about a hundred thousand dollars two
hundred thousand a million
three million four million whatever then
that means i failed my mission right
okay so so i'm uh on that path to
to not fail and that's how much i
believe in myself and what i do
but at the same time like no matter what
how much i believe in
believe in myself every dumb purchase i
do there's a smart purchase right you
know it's like
you know i probably own like seven
million in real estate just
over so every every if i give away three
hundred thousand like i probably bought
a condo or something you know that's
right you know i'm saying so was kind of
like
like right now like i could get i could
lose everything and so yeah then today
it's like i got
seven million or whatever in in condos
and houses and [ __ ]
right but i don't care like if i have
you know um i believe in myself
so much right now and what and
and what what i'm about to do if i'm
tripping about a million dollars
then that means i failed so all right
what is your mission
to be a billionaire gonna be a
billionaire all right to be a
billionaire yeah do you have a timeline
for that
three to five years three to five years
damn yeah so
like pardon my ignorance but uh
how did you come into this situation
just straight youtube
you just no dude so i had a really
shitty [ __ ] day right like when i was
young
i was young as [ __ ] and uh at that point
i hated my life this night i was like yo
like i'm sick of this like and then i
started making instagram videos like i'm
like
i'm done with this [ __ ] and i always
thought that i would be like uh
like a streamer like i would stream and
work out and be that youtube guy because
i would watch like for example like
phase boys face clan i'd watch them
when i was younger i was like yo this
this guy just bought like a flat screen
tv
like that's crazy like i want a flat
screen tv right those guys throw money
around pretty much
i'm saying it's like but it was like i
had like the
shittiest day of my life and i was like
you know what [ __ ] this like
i'm i'm doing this and that's when i
started um
drinking liquor on instagram okay
so i started the first video when you're
in high school in high school yeah and i
was on probation
for what for for marijuana okay yeah i
got arrested like three times for
marijuana it's ridiculous
where what state did you grow up in in
florida florida ridiculous where in
florida
uh near orlando oviedo florida but it
was like i had the shittiest day of my
life and he was like
i was like [ __ ] you [ __ ] everyone like
i'm gonna do this [ __ ] and then i posted
a video of me slamming a whole bottle of
fireball
and it was like it was crazy because i
gained like hundreds of followers i was
like yo
like i'm the [ __ ] like you know man i
never had good things happen when i
chugged hard liquor
it was oh every time it was bad news
well dude one time my buddy and i
[ __ ]
chugged big huge glasses of whiskey
and then we blacked out we didn't know
what happened turns out my buddy
fell through a [ __ ] glass
door straight glass door he fell down
and he landed on it like
it's jagged on the bottom cut his elbow
all the way through everything
[ __ ] cut it through the bone and like
he would have been dead bled out except
for
the neighbor heard the [ __ ] glass
break and thought there was a [ __ ]
break-in
they thought that the house was being
burgled so they called the cops and the
cops came and found
us both unconscious in the gnarliest
[ __ ] pool of blood you've ever seen
and like that's the only reason that
[ __ ] didn't die
another time dude i woke up on the hood
of a [ __ ] car because i had crashed
my bicycle
[ __ ] out of my teeth the first time i
broke teeth dude
so you were driving i was riding my
bicycle home and i [ __ ]
next thing you know i'm on the hood of a
parked car so you were
you were [ __ ] up yeah yeah i blacked
out every time i chugged hard liquor
but it worked great for you he gained a
lot of followers
yeah yeah i gained a lot of followers
but it was a slow grind i mean
it's like how many followers did you
have at that point on instagram i mean
he said he got hundreds of followers
yeah so i was i was doing two to three
liquor slams drinking stunts that i i
took myself to
110 where it's like like right now like
i can't even go into the mindset that i
was in back then because back then i was
hungry hungry not that i'm not hungry
right now
but like right now it's like i got
everything in the world
like back then i had nothing it was like
it's i couldn't even
at all you can eat wings i couldn't even
afford the ranch
you know what i'm saying so it was a
different level
of hungriness you know what i'm saying
so i was like i literally
had drinking superpowers
like because it was like i was at a
whole nother level like
i was here it was like all you can eat
wings i couldn't even afford ranch
so it was it was at a whole nother level
of hungriness to where it's like
i legit had super powers yeah
i do not possess now i have i have them
but they're not at the cape
back then bro i could do anything i feel
like
anything you all right how much of uh
i mean i guess i know the answer to this
i was gonna say how much of is alcohol
like part of the deal
but my my editor was telling me he's
like dude that guy's deal is just
[ __ ] uh alcohol he drinks like uh no
i'm trying
i'm trying i mean that's that was like
before but
right now i like i don't i don't have to
drink like that to
to get what i got can i just tell you
how [ __ ] up my new tour is
it's completely multimedia legitimately
x-rated there's legal waivers all over
the venue because i'm
actually worried about getting sued and
i don't give a [ __ ] man
because it's gnarly and it's all the
stuff i wasn't allowed to do on jackass
so get to my [ __ ] website stevo.com
and get your tickets man especially with
this movie coming out dude
they're all gonna sell dude so hurry up
while you can get seats